hay mucha expectativa sobre un eventual
ces el fuego sobre todo después de lo
que ocurrió en diciembre cuando el eln
desmintió que hubiera llegado hasta el
acuerdo con el gobierno qué tan factible
es llegar a un ces el fuego en esta
Ronda de negociaciones
Bueno siempre tiene sus complicaciones
se trata de un tema que involucra no
solamente al ejército de liberación
nacional
las comunidades en los territorios lo
están pidiendo en segundo lugar Pues hay
una experiencia que se dio con el
gobierno el presidente Santos donde el
eln y el gobierno es vacunarnos ese
bilateral que fue exitoso en su momento
y por lo tanto es una experiencia con la
cual se puede trabajar
una de las situaciones que preocupa es
que a diferencia de las FARC Esta no es
una organización con una sola línea de
Mando qué tan fácil será llegar a un
eventual acuerdo
que tiene sus complejidades pero en el
fondo lo que lo que estamos viendo Es
que en cuanto a la decisión de sentarse
mayor
unidad además estamos ante una situación
histórica Es la primera vez que hay un
gobierno de izquierda
encabezado por el presidente Gustavo
Pedro que a su vez fue también parte de
un proceso de paz y por lo tanto hay
unas condiciones
únicas e históricas que nos permiten
tener grados de optimismo esto no quiere
decir que sea fácil
ignorar las complejidades que hay en el
terreno pero sí creo que estamos ante
una oportunidad que muestra muchos
elementos que no
habían existido
Qué temas estructurarían este eventual
nueva acuerdo
central para el acuerdo
es el tema de la participación de la
sociedad
distinto a lo que fue
en que la sociedad debe jugar un papel
protagónico en todo el proceso y por lo
tanto si se logra un acuerdo sobre este
tema en nodal para para el acuerdo sería
sería un paso muy importante para
avanzar hacia otros aspectos que ojalá
puedan desembocar el acuerdo final